[Music]
welcome to the beautiful countryside of
Thailand where each jack fruit is more
than just a fruit it's a testament to
the patience and love for the land held
by the people here today we'll follow
Thai Farmers on their Journey from Tiny
seeds to harvesting these giant Jack
fruits this is a story of dedication
tradition and pride passed down through
generations in Thailand every jackf
fruit carries the sweet taste and the
story of meticulous care join us as we
begin the journey to discover the
process of growing nurturing and
harvesting this unique
[Music]
fruit it all starts with a seed carrying
not just potential but a legacy these
seeds chosen from the juiciest and
healthiest Jack fruits of the previous
Harvest hold the promise of another
Bountiful season in the skilled hands of
these Farmers each seed is nurtured with
care ensuring the continuation of a
tradition passed down through
generations these seeds are lovingly
nurtured placed into hand prepared soil
beds where they receive just the right
amount of sunlight water and attention
as they sprout into delicate seedlings
their Journey towards becoming the sweet
Giants of the field truly begins
under the watchful eyes of the farmers
these seedlings grow strong and
resilient once ready they are
transplanted into the fields where their
growth will continue until they are
ready to bear
[Music]
fruit planting a Jackfruit tree is a
labor of love rooted in Tradition each
seedling is placed in the ground with
Precision ensuring it has enough space
to grow and Thrive with patience the
farmers work tirelessly using techniques
refined over
[Music]
Generations weeding around the base of
the trees is an essential part of the
Care process the farmers meticulously
remove each weed keeping the soil around
the trees clean and well ventilated
allowing the trees to absorb all the
nutrients they need to grow strong this
timec consuming and labor intensive work
is crucial to ensuring the Jackfruit
trees don't have to compete with weeds
for
nutrients with such careful attention
the jackf fruit trees grow stronger each
day preparing for a Bountiful Harvest
from from watering and fertilizing to
weeding every step contributes to
nurturing the sweet jack fruit that will
soon reach everyone's
hands after years of care the trees
finally bear their bounty
[Music]
the Jack fruits grow to impressive sizes
sometimes reaching up to 90 cm in length
and weighing as much as 30 kg but the
real art lies in knowing when they are
ready the farmers listen for that
perfect Hollow sound as they tap the
Rind signaling that the fruit is at its
peak
harvesting jack fruit is a delicate art
that requires both precision and
experience honed over many seasons the
process starts early in the morning when
the air is cool and the light is just
right with a skilled hand the farmer
uses a sharp knife to make a clean
careful cut at the stem Precision is key
to avoid damaging the fruit or the tree
Once cut the jack fruit is is gently
lowered or caught by another farmer
ensuring it doesn't bruise upon
[Music]
Landing hey
hey hey
[Music]
[Applause]
hey hey
[Music]
harvesting jack fruit is more than just
a task it's the culmination of months of
hard work the Jack fruits are then
loaded on to carts ready for their
Journey to the market or processing
facilities each fruit is a testament to
the farmers's dedication and skill a
moment of Pride and
[Music]
fulfillment once harvested these Jack
fruits make their way to the heart of
Thailand's vibrant Street markets here
the fruit is transformed into a popular
street food where vendors skillfully
slice and package the sweet golden flesh
the aroma of ripe jack fruit fills the
air drawing locals and tourists alike to
experience the Taste of Thailand street
food is where the true essence of jack
fruit is appreciated sold fresh this
fruit is a favorite snack known for its
unique sweetness and satisfying texture
it's a simple pleasure that connects the
people of Thailand to their land and
tradition
[Music]
TI jack fruit has long been a favorite
fresh fruit loved by both locals and
tourists for its sweet aromatic flavor
however to extend its shelf life and
create a delicious snack Jackfruit
undergos a modern processing method in
factories here carefully selected ripe
Jack fruits are sliced and then dried
with Precision the drying process
preserves the unique flavor of the jackf
fruit transforming it into a convenient
and nutritious treat that is enjoyed
worldwide
[Music]
he for